it's definitely a milestone moment
the purchasing power is strong the
appreciation of culture is very strong
[Music]
the korean art market has really been
booming these past couple of years and
just now it's gaining attention
internationally
the current reputation of korean artists
has gone up much more compared to 10
years ago they're demonstrating strong
auction results in and out of korea
their sales have increased dramatically
as well
south korea is making its mark on the
art world
in 2017 its contemporary art market was
valued at 378 million dollars that
number is expected to surpass 700
million in 2022 according to a report by
the korea arts management service while
still small compared to the global art
market which was valued at 65 billion
dollars in 2021 it's seeing a lot of
buzz and interest
freeze is known as one of the largest
contemporary art fairs in the world
it just opened its first edition in
seoul featuring over 110 galleries
coming from 21 countries the market here
has deep roots and strong foundations
but it is trending younger and to a
broader audience i think freeze choosing
seoul for their launch in asia really
validates what's happening
renowned international galleries like
pace peritong and lehman maupin are
expanding their footprint here
demonstrating their faith in the market
it has everything it has
great artists great traditions
great institutions i think the potential
and the trend is big partly because of
the stability korea brings
and purchasing activity from south
korean collectors in the contemporary
art sector increased 258
in 2021 from the year before according
to auction house phillips
so what's fueling this growth
i think the fact that they weren't
traveling as much that gave an
opportunity to sort of explore you know
the local art scene and to learn more
about that i think that was something
that's not just exclusive to korea
you've seen that sort of globally
i'm thinking
hong kong and therefore china southeast
asia or even korean collectors couldn't
enter hong kong because of the covet
restrictions korea is looking like a
very stable haven in east asia
the tax rates are very favorable for
collecting art taxes are exempt for
artworks that cost under approximately
50 000 us dollars taxes are exempt for
living artists
with technological development it's
become much easier to promote shows and
artwork previously we had to gather all
the media do a press conference and send
out exhibition brochures these days we
can just post a photo on instagram and
people will come
i would say that our
connection to
exchanging visual art
images has grown through
the internet social platform
we've definitely seen a huge surge of
young collectors collectors in their 20s
and 30s a lot of them are
internationally educated so they don't
have a problem with contacting galleries
abroad
and they're very proactive about their
research
the younger generation started seeing
the collection as a type of asset like
stock or bitcoin gen z and millennials
realize you can buy art hang it on a
wall and show it off through social
media and that's become a medium to
express one's identity as well as a tool
of investment
soul designer tao yang has been
accumulating his own collection of art
for around 10 years
collecting art
it could be a very good investment tool
but i want people to invest more on what
they could learn from this process you
know we cannot forget their contribution
to our history
these active groups of young collectors
they are not just filled with all this
data but they really know how to utilize
that and i think it's very different
from our older generations of collectors
despite such growth and declarations of
seoul as asia's new art capital many say
hong kong isn't giving up its crown just
yet
hong kong's 3 billion art market still
has the largest concentration of blue
chip international galleries in asia
and seoul's auction market is still a
fraction of the size of china's in the
first half of the year it saw
115.5 million dollars in fine arts sales
compared with china's 2.4 billion
dollars
[Music]
south korea was and will remain a hub is
it going to replace part of asia
like china and hong kong and the truth
is we don't know we'll be able to judge
it probably in 10 15 years
this is also a calling for the local
galleries to
foster and cultivate the careers of
local artists and remain an individual
presence within the korean art scene
people know korean film they know k-pop
they know fashion design of course why
wouldn't art be as strong and it is as
strong
[Music]
you